oh
bonjour et bienvenue sur diagonale
l'actualité internationale du jeu
d'échecs alors aujourd'hui au programme
l'actualité de canal web dépôt de bilan
de redressement judiciaire et compagnie
également nous aurons les commentaires
sur le championnat du monde sur internet
évidemment c des qualifications sur
internet c'est très très compliqué
triche ou pas tricher bien nous en
saurons plus également etienne bacrot
qui fait un match contre émile suite
office qui le champion d'europe en titre
et qui est en train de mener le match
alors nous avons évidemment pour
présenter cette émission notre
présentateur vedette stéphane laborde
bonjour web vous jouez loi alors donc
actualité chargée on va y revenir avec
pour ça on invitait que tu va nous
présenter une fois de plus - m et
nouveaux de nouveau mais il est des
livres n'y a pas longtemps visite vient
tout le temps ils viennent tout le temps
donc c'est jean-luc chavanon invité
permanent maître international et donc
et ancien maître international grand
maître maintenant et non mais ça c'est
normal il a été le maire pendant très
longtemps maintenant ils les grands
maîtres et donc il est de retour sur
diagonale pour avec maintenant son
nouveau statut de grand maître qui a eu
un peu de mal à digérer et aux
championnats de france mais ça va
revenir dans quel en jean luc tu seras
en phase de digestion du titre devant m
ah oui donc je suis en phase de
digestion g j'ai souffert du syndrome
donc du titre de grand maître
international c'est à dire qu'ils vont
dès qu'on obtient ce titre en général
c'est la gamelle
donc bon maintenant je vais le lire plus
sérieusement dans dans la compétition on
verra en fin d'émission tu l'auras un
tournoi à menton
très bientôt donc là on espère te revoir
en plateforme alors aujourd'hui nous
allons parler d'eux canal web pour en
savoir plus la semaine dernière nous
recevions jacques rosselin qui nous
disait dépôt de bilan effectivement donc
stéphane que s'est il passé
il y a eu une bonne et une mauvaise
nouvelle oui bah disons que on s'y
attendait quand même un peu c'est à dire
que le tribunal de commerce a décidé
qu'à noël pouvait continuer son activité
donc ça me titille les actionnaires
historiques de canadiens ont décidé de
remettre au pot alors maintenant de
remettre un petit coup effectivement
donc de continuer l'activité simplement
pour que ce soit validé par le trident
commerce il faut que ce soit une
activité qui soit financièrement
équilibrée que ça n'augmente pas le
passif est donc pour ça il faut se
concentrer sur les activités de canal
web qui rapporte de l'argent aujourd'hui
et les seules activités qui rapportent
de l'argent sont le 'b to b' c'est à
dire le service aux entreprises
il faut le rappeler diagonale ne gagne
pas d'argent a plutôt tendance à en
perdre ben ouais le gagnent pas d'argent
parce qu'on n'a rien fait pour mettre en
place des abonnements ou mettre en place
un système qui permettrait d'en gagner
simplement n'a pas eu le temps de le
faire parce que c'était pas prévu de le
faire aussi tôt c'est peut-être dommage
mais c'est comme ça donc il est très
probable mais pas sûr sur absolument
encore que des gones s'arrête c'est pas
encore sûr puisqu'il possible que
quelques programmes continuent donc vous
en saurez plus très prochainement on
vous tiendra au courant soit par la
newsletter soient en direct de vive voix
vous en saurez plus sur l'avenir de
diagonale en maintenant le grand débat
de cette semaine c'est donc le
championnat du monde fis des il y avait
qualifié par le classement elo il ya des
qualifiés par zone et il y a huit places
pour les joueurs qui se qualifieraient
sur internet
alors ce qu'est ce que ça veut dire ça
veut dire que les joueurs sont devant
leur ordinateur on leur donne un
appariement leur donne un horaire de jeu
et là ils sont libres de jouer
maintenant
personne n'est là pour vérifier que le
joueur joue tout seul il peut donc être
accompagnés d'autres joueurs de grand
maître expérimenté de grandes et très
fort et évidemment d'ordinateur donc
tout ça pose un problème évidemment
moral on voit des joueurs non classés
qui joue un niveau de grand maître
international
ça paraît tout à fait mouche alors jean
luc ton analyse en tant que joueur
professionnel de ce système de
qualification sur internet les avantages
les inconvénients et les avantages c'est
que quelque part on peut dire ça
démocratise un petit peu le jeu d'échecs
ça permet un amateur donc de se
qualifier aux championnats du monde un
joueur qui est nettement moins fort que
les autres joueurs
bon donc ça c'est l' avantage ce qui
fait que tout le monde a envie de
participer à cette compétition
l'inconvénient c'est que finalement
c'est celui qui est quand même le mieux
équipé et kiala la plus grosse puissance
de machines qui qui qui va probablement
se qualifier localement est-ce qu'on
peut dire que tous les joueurs jouent
avec des machines ça c'est important
peut-on jouer sans ordinateur à côté
j'imagine mal donc actuellement donc vu
le classement qu'obtiennent certaines
machines qui aux alentours de 2650
j'imagine mal un joueur même
enfin joueurs de ma force essayer de
jouer ce genre de compétition sans
machine d'ailleurs moi c'est la raison
pour laquelle j'ai décidé de ne pas y
participer
on va rappeler quand même jean-luc que
les machines sont interdites alors elles
sont interdites mais en même temps on
peut pas contrôler une aberration de
règlement ses fans
non mais bon du moment qu'on peut pas
contrôler on ne peut pas appliquer un
règlement ça c'est ça c'est clair
quand il ya eu le contrôle anti doping
ne contient une loi il ya une police ci
a pas de police il ya pas de bois c'est
pas de contrôle c'est pas la peine de
faire une loi c'est ça ne sert à rien en
plus on a du mal à comprendre comment
vérifier puisque si si un joueur utilise
deux ordinateurs une machine pour
travailler pour analyser la position et
notre machine pour pour transmettre les
coûts donc sur le serveur internet
donc on imagine que comment faire un
contrôle il n'y a pas deux il n'y a pas
de solution c'est un règlement il y à
une pollution il ya une solution qui
existe on va quand même là l'un appelé
la fille d il ya pensé on peut porter
réclamation en disant voilà mon
adversaire a joué tous les coups de
l'ordinateur vérifiez vous prenez les
temps de réflexion vous regardez ce que
donne l'ordinateur après tel temps de
réflexion et vous voyez il a joué
systématiquement le coup l'ordinateur
neeson de deviner quel programme
il faut deviner quel programme puisqu'il
joue pas tous les mêmes coûts en plus
pour porter réclamation il faut quand
même payer 200 dollars
ouais donc tout le monde n'a pas envie
de porter réclamation c'est évident donc
voilà donc finalement en pratique il n'y
aura jamais de contrôle et donc tout le
monde peut il ya quand même eu il ya
quand même eu un contre-exemple kasparov
avait organisé grand prix sur internet
qui a eu lieu l'an dernier qui avait
perdu d'ailleurs elle a perdu en finale
contre rio une piquette
mais dans cette compétition là il y
avait un arbitre
chez chaque joueur oui tout à fait mais
là c'était limité à 16 joueurs compris
kasparov donc on pouvait envoyer des
arbitres à ces endroits différents
la com il ya 64 joueurs on peut pas
envoyer des arbitres à 64 mois
différents pour y fiez pas c'est pas les
mêmes joueurs espagnols joueurs donc
voilà donc alors bon exemple en pratique
avant de commenter etienne bacrot contre
sitôt ce qui est bien une partie d'olic
et touzanne le joug sympathique joueur
toulousain maintenant montpelliérains
toujours très sympathique et olivier
touzanne qui scorent un maximum
puisqu'il est actuellement deuxième de
la compétition avec trois points et demi
sur 4 en ayant battu des très fortes oui
donc olivier tout jeune qui est maître
international qui
qui a donc un résultat assez fantastique
par rapport à son à son rang dans la
hiérarchie internationale et qui est en
passe de se qualifier donc pour une
compétition pour laquelle je pense que
il n'aurait pas forcément sa place en
suivant le conduire le cycle classique
c'est à dire le championnat d'europe
tout simplement je pense que je peux à
d'europe il y à il ya beaucoup trop de
grands maîtres de premier plan et c'est
très très difficile alors à noter quand
même on va un peu faire le tour des
joueurs qui participent à cette
compétition on voit deux par exemple
sergei shitov qui est un virus
extrêmement fort wauquiez vix le joueur
polonais laurent frayssinet christian
bauer igor nataf tout une tout un tas de
grands maîtres français et bien entendu
des inconnus ont des illustres inconnus
que personne ne connaît qu'on n'a jamais
vues qui sont non classés des fois et
qui a aussi deux font partie de la tête
du classement il faut aussi voir la
performance exceptionnelle de certains
sartoux gaëtan gaëtan sartoux militants
sartoux qui lui n'est pas maître
international je crois est qui et qui
fait une performance incroyable vraiment
incroyable des parties fantastique donc
on peut supposer beaucoup de choses il a
terminé le buzz et voudrait signer mais
de tout cela dans les rangs français
de toute façon je crois que c'est
surtout la fidh et qui à remettre
comment dire le le règlement la fidh et
qui remettent en question finalement
puisque tout le monde semble utiliser
des ordinateurs pourquoi l'interdire
finalement on va dire que ce championnat
sera un championnat de dhe curie ce sera
des échecs avancer les échecs avancées
avec des grosses écuries donc une
éclipse toute une team qui qui soutient
le joueur donc qui donne son nom au
finalement il donne son nom à une sorte
de marque
donc on peut même supposer que la balle
en serait là mais ne jouerait pas par
exemple on peut dire que si ça se trouve
sous l'ipa n'a pas joué une seule partie
c'est son team qui a joué à sa place
exacte je n'aime pas besoin d'être
présent il peut simplement encaissé la
place elle en finale et ensuite on envie
de rock l'envisager tout un tas de
possibilités
bon on va tout de suite passé au niveau
de jeu qui est totalement incroyable
vraiment des parties d'une qualité
remarquable c'est du semi rapide c'est
surprenant
olivier tout vannes contre tête brand
alors tout de suite la partie olivier
touzanne à l'eiblen c'est qu'ils se
taisent grandes têtes blondes sont
américains
que jean-luc connaît sans doute têtes
blondes donc c'est un grand spécialiste
du jeu du jeu sur internet c'est un
joueur amateur qui doit avoir un niveau
donc est un niveau modeste mais qui qui
a su s'équiper et qui doit avoir quand
même des connaissances du jeu correct
qui a su s'équiper donc qui a préparé
donc sont comment dire son matériel
informatique pour pour ce championnat du
monde et ses résultats
c'est une supputation évidemment on n'a
pas de preuves on n'a pas de preuve ne
vaut pas le prouver mais bon donc c'est
un joueur finalement donc actuellement
l'intérêt finalement c'est une sorte de
guerre stratégique aux championnats du
monde c'est à dire utilisez donc des des
armes technologiques
donc on peut supposer que lier tous
donnent aussi évidemment utiliser un
ordinateur exactement
donc maintenant on utilise des armes
technologiques pour vaincre son
adversaire sur sur l'échiquier ça
devient ça devient je dirais oui de la
science-fiction exactement vient alors
la partie des quatre cavaliers f6 ses
capes capeps 3g 6 j'ai trois ans alors
j'ai trois c1
ça amène plutôt des positions fermes et
donc un peu anti ordinateur peut-être
fou g7 fou g2 petit rock petit rock des
six c4 donc là on est dans la position
de base de l'internet g3 pour en savoir
plus vous pouvez aller dans diagonale la
leçon je vais la défense escales
indiennes contre j'ai 3 vous aurez tout
un tas d analyse sur cette position ou
g3 qui est une des armes les plus
redoutables contre l'estonienne avec la
baïonnette
oui et d'ailleurs je crois que garry
kasparov lui-même la refuse
en général ils préfèrent jouer des 5es
et transposé dans une grande poêle ne
pas jouer avec des six jouée ces six des
5 avec une position équilibrée il a fait
beaucoup de nuls contre anatoli karpov
en tout cas les noirs sont en défense il
avait d'ailleurs joué une partie
remarquable contre contre vladislav
quatre chefs à la coupe du monde donc où
il avait fait ils avaient fait match nul
n'avait pas gagné avec les noirs mais
c'était une partie d'une combativité
incroyable qu'elle valait 17 kms est 3e
donc là c'est une réaction normale des
noirs c'est une variante tout à fait
classique eux quatre ces six là c'est la
théorie tous âges en lui ici les blancs
au centre ne peuvent pas bouger ce pion
puisque s'ils prennent ça ségalis tout
de suite après des problèmes s'ils
avancent
eh bien ça donne trop de cases on peut
jouer avec d'un v6 qui a laissé cinq des
plans comme ça il n'y a pas de problème
pour les noirs donc ici les blancs ne
bouge pas au centre c'est le principe
et ils essayent de provoquer les noirs à
prendre en d4 fait ils veulent que les
noirs prennent en d4 pour reprendre les
cavaliers et ensuite attaqué pions des
six le l'idée positionnelle de cette
ouverture c'est ça donc ici on joue un
petit coup on joue h3 l'idée c'est le
développement naturel du foot sur la
case de 3,5 rhin de cavalerie 430 kg cas
tout à fait stéphane puisque le pion
contrôle
donc ça c'est l'idée ici si les noirs
jouent normal eh bien on sait pas trop
ce qu'ils peuvent faire
parce qu'ils ont envie de sortir leurs
pièces mais le président n'a pas
beaucoup c'est vite a pas beaucoup de
casse donc c'est difficile de se
développer sans prendre là puisqu'on
sait pas quoi faire de notre cavalier 17
donc une des variantes qui existent ses
pions prend des quatre est classé 5 sur
paul et blanc vont achever ce qu'il
voulait c'est à dire la colonne des semi
ouverte sur actions des six et si les
noirs ne prennent pas en d4 et bien on
ne sait pas trop ce qu'ils vont faire
il ya une alternative c'est le coût d'un
v6 la variante hautement théorique
puisque la sueur fou et roy hill et adam
prend b2 donc évidemment et la menace
ception prend des 4 et cavalli prend 1,4
avec un poêle où j'essaie d'être qui se
réveille ce qui est dit donc ça donne
mais si c'est un coup reconnu par la
théorie comme étant assez forte et une
contre contrepoint en fait normal on
joue taurin ça c'est la grande ligne
tours 1
mais il ya également la position mis au
point par alexei shirov pour la première
fois contre garry kasparov la partie de
référence c'est le coup c'est 5
oui donc je précise un petit peu puisque
je connais très très bien ce genre de
position que que ces cinq donc est
actuellement donc la ligne ce n'est
peut-être pas la grande ligne mais c'est
la ligne qui est joué par les joueurs
tops mondiaux donc depuis cette fameuse
partie de alexei shirov je crois même
que yusupov aussi à jouer ça donc depuis
ces parties là où on a vu que les blancs
obtenez vraiment des chances d'attac
incroyable les blancs se sont mis à
jouer cette ligne est récemment donc il
ya le l'ancien champion du monde
kalichman qui avait gagné une très très
belle partie avec avec cette ligne donc
qu'elle beaucoup de parties de référence
1 les parties de référence évidemment
c'est ce qui détermine la théorie
moderne
la théorie c'est l'ensemble des
positions existantes donc maintenant
c'est 5 et le coup statistiquement le
plus joué le plus représentatif de
l'évolution de la théorie échiquéenne
dans cette position et donc après ses
cinq il ya une fuite forcée jean-luc
mais là on est obligé de prendre du
plomb des hans et 5
oui puisque la dame et attaquer donc
rupture des six aussi ouais je dépensais
500 prend au sein qui en prend 2,5 non
matin les noirs à jouer cavalier huit
cavaliers hui le seul coup 8
voilà donc ces cinq et qui est un
sacrifice de pions alors pour l'instant
c'est toujours l'égalité matériel mais
tu vas 5 est perdu mais le pion aux 5es
perdu donc dans cette position alors que
je ferai faire transmis par exemple
jean-louis pour défendre le pion mais
c'est pas très intéressant parce que les
noirs j'aurais simplement qui a laissé
cette équipe vit aussi ce une variante
dans ce style par exemple ou peut-être
dame prend b2 peut-être même privé de
aussi en tout cas dans sa position les
blancs ont une ressource incroyable donc
c'est le coup tout simple hum hum 5,6
tout simple ce n'est pas vraiment le mot
l'idée de secours donc que six les noirs
sont obligés de prendre puisque la
menace est non seulement bien croquer
mali mais aussi pions pouces ramassant
la tour donc il faut prendre enfin là et
maintenant
donc là il ya vraiment eu un sacrifice
de pions mais quelles en sont les
compensations
balleux je crois que le mot qui pourrait
qualifier donc les compensations
seraient
ce raid est structuré on pourrait dire
que les noirs dans sa position sont
déstructurées c'est à dire que leur
structure de pion à les droits par
exemple avec h7 g6 et e6 est plus
fragile que scipion que lorsque le pion
itélé sur la case ex est tout à fait
merci à quatre contre trois on est de ce
côté là donc là effectivement les blancs
sont en train de monter ce qu'on appelle
une attaque contre le roi 1 il faut bien
faut bien le dire le plan d' attaque et
bien il est magnifiquement illustré par
cette partie et c'est une très bonne
stratégie de la part d'olivier touzanne
qui s'il considère que son adversaire ne
se joue pas très bien aux échecs mais en
revanche dispose d'un ordinateur
puissant on sait que le point faible des
ordinateurs et bien c'est quand ils sont
attaqués en le roi est attaqué très
précisément on peut déjà dire que têtes
blondes dans cette position a fait un
mauvais choix d'ouverture avec une
machine on peut déjà trouver des
conclusions stratégique donc dans cet
emploi donc de l'ordinateur pour pour la
victoire
maintenant reste au conditionnel
stéphane parce qu'on n'est pas sûr à
100% qu'il jouait de machines mais c'est
probable oui c'est hautement protégé ça
attaque le pion aux sites dont il avait
dit je sens que c'est la manoeuvre quasi
classique pour ce type de position
donc on attaque tout de suite le pion le
plus faible le maillon faible le pion
aux six exactement d'autant plus qu'on
laisse ensuite le pion f avancé
puisqu'il n'est plus bloquée par akiva
lieu restaurant le nord peuvent pas
bloquer avec 6 e 5 au 6 e 5 alors
stéphane saf a l'air très bon puisque sa
fébrilité blanche mais je pense qu'on
peut jouer tout simplement
cavalier e 6 oui on peut aller prendre
le fou g7
c'est une possibilité est-ce qu'il y en
a d'autres bac avis aussi ça a l'air
assez fort bonjour et cabello six
attaques la tour en attaque
le fou également au passage des petites
menaces avec cavaliers a quarter
l'option c5 donc ici après un coup comme
tour m6 par exemple on perdrait angers7
on peut aussi jouer cavalier web et on
peut prendre on prend g7 qui avait des
projets 7 et la foulée 5 par exemple
avec une position compliquée mais on va
jouer sans doute avec f4 fins et yann
initiative initiative
à noter que c'est pas évident qu'il va
lui aussi se souvenir pourquoi jean luc
dionne oui parce que les cases blanches
sont affaiblis peut-être
un coup comme dames 2 peut aussi
profiter de l'affaiblissement des causes
blanche pour jouer dame ces quatre
échecs ce genre de chose d'être plutôt
un bon coup avec la menace aussi de
développement semblent à l'étroit
ouais d'abord sans doute préférable ici
je sens que c'est possible
zhang de toute façon le 5 est possible
mais c'est un coup quand même un
séducteur kg cinq cavaliers aux cinq
donc avait lieu sans qui le coût normal
donc normal puisqu'on leur venir en aide
cette avec mourinho est fait pour
échanger ce cavalier dangereux angers ça
et ça protège le pian bien aussi c'est
le fou ces huit défend le pion aux six
oui hein
donc tout ça c'est important c'est
encore la théorie s4 cavale ça cavaliers
f7 cavaliers problème cette épreuve set
et l'a donc dans la partie lointain dans
la partie dont j'ai parlé tout à l'heure
la partie de qualif man qui la jouait je
crois contre oui contre le numéro un
mexicain gilberto hernandez oui j'irai
des sept partis d'ailleurs récemment
puisque gilberto à hernandez était
l'invité donc on a des prix du tournoi
d'evry donc
dans cette partie le joueur mexicain
avait repris de la tour directement en
offset et cet effet et s'était retrouvé
avec un four fermé après le coup eux 4 5
le 4 au 5 donc le fou et angers 7 ans
fermes et le plan des blancs en
maintenant ses cavaliers ou 4 h 4 h
saint pendant vers une illustration dans
la partie une illustration dans une
position similaire mais ici le fou g7 se
retrouver enfermé donc au lieu de
reprendre 27 on peut asséner un échec
intermedia fou des quatre échecs quatre
échecs le fou il pas prenable évidemment
il défendu courage de très logique et
maintenant pour prendre ce qui fait que
le fou est beaucoup plus actif ici qu'il
ne l'était en jce est exactement
d'autant plus que les blancs sont quand
même obligé de jouer aux cinq une petite
intérêt à prendre ce qu'a laissé trois
finalement alors pour lequel ces 3
stéphane c'est extrêmement responsable
normand responsable parce que quand on a
pris ce cavalier
on amène à une fois été ce cavalier va
être très actif aussi puisqu'il va
sauter sur le gazon 4 visant les cases
faible des six fils éventuellement g5
donc on va montrer l'énorme problème de
france et trois ans les femmes c'est
qu'après pions prend c'est pas les cases
noires qui sont faites ça c'est un
problème sur le long terme ça on a plus
de flou pour défendre les 4 mars et la
colonne des qui maintenant est ouverte
et donc les blancs peuvent y accéder
facilement
donc comment je vous tombent déjà dans
cette position pas facile difficile de
trouver ne serait-ce qu'un seul coup
puisque tours 17 n'est pas du tout
constructif pour des services en ti à
sac la dame mais ça n'a aucun sens
pêches maritimes gk tout dameuse manager
catalan damien catala fordham de a l'air
très bien également à venir fouet trois
tournées un joueur très très belle
position pour les blancs qui malgré
leurs pions de - n'ont absolument pas
s'inquiéter
dans cette situation on voit que les
pièces noires sont englués l'a nettement
à gauche de l'échiquier la torah 8 et le
fou ces huit sont vraiment fous très
très mal placée france et 3 ce n'est pas
un coup qu'on pourrait recommander à
près de 5
en revanche kbc 7 est un coup très
logique on veut revenir sur les caisses
des 5 voilà peut pas faire plus logique
que c'est les noirs ont des cases au
centre faut les exploiter on a déjà mis
un point d cap maintenant on va mettre
un cavalier en d5
maintenant que se passe-t-il cavaliers
au calme mais voilà ce qu'avait
deviennent très fort viande et 6 tout de
suite ils ont en effet si la date d'il
ya cent ans g5y rayonne ce cavalier il
et il est très fort qu'à valider cinq
contrôles et lacazette si c'était quand
même la case la plus importante est
maintenant plan de jeu
comment est ce que les blancs font pour
améliorer leurs positions ça n'a pas
l'air si c'est parce qu'on a dû tout à
l'heure c'est qu'il faut remarquer c'est
qu'effectivement les rois les noirs en
leur roi un petit peu en l'air oui
puisque les pions sont peu disloqué et
les blancs en capturant contre 3 de ce
côté donc a priori c'est quand même de
ce côté qu'il faut agir il faut de toute
façon attaqué droit mais maintenant
comment faire puisqu'on ne peut plus
attaquées avec les pièces ça a l'air
clair mais aussi de casser la structure
l'aller faut essayer de casser
structures d'appui en faire un plan
d'action fort bien d'un plan d'un bélier
après le mobilier implantions qui
évidemment n'est jamais pratiquement
envisagée par l'ordinateur ce genre de
coups l'ordinateur verrait plutôt des
coups comme qui est des six qui ne
servent à rien puisque l'ordinateur ne
sait pas faire un plan de jeu à
proprement parler ou en tout cas il a du
mal
donc le bon coup trouvé par olivier tout
dan h41 très fort oui donc hqe attaque
ou un coup très très fort un coup très
logique
ce qui est quand même usant dans cette
position c'est de voir que les blancs
n'ont pas développé leur tour et leur
fouet lors c'est vrai quand même et il
attaque quand même alors bon c'est pas
pas très conventionnel c'est pas très
classique
c'est vrai mais il se trouve que
il est quand même difficile de
d'attaquer ce roi en h2 oui laurent
blanc est extrêmement bien s'intéresser
qui n'atteint que le pion b2 et défendu
aussi de manière indirecte
voyez sur france 2 il ya tour b1 le
fousseret cloud et oui mais encadrées
sur la dame le fou d'ailleurs ce qui
fait que on peut se permettre donc de
pousser et c'est quand même un des
développements les plus utiles aux
positions saisir que h 4 h 5
c'est assez fort parce qu'une fois qu'on
a joué cinq dont jude mg 4 la dame à la
base c'est en attaque l'option de l'es6
en force donc ça c'est plutôt plutôt une
menace assez directe d'amd vite jouée
par tête brandon whitney sont certains
ne fait plus rien des séances b6 ces
jeunes installés bouché par le pion csii
notamment 16e peu pression sur le cube
et 2 mais bon h 50 quand même très
logique
toujours dans l'idée d'amener carte
puisqu'on voit que la dame en débitant
fait et bien ne peut pas venir lui par
clic à son contrôle et donc pas de
problème tous rêvent cinq attaques du
pion en fait ce coup cherchent à
provoquer les blancs à prendre et noir
veulent que les blancs prennent comme ça
après après la reprise est bien il
espère pouvoir utiliser la colonne h
mais doit évidemment ou f3 donc ça s'est
extrêmement bien joué de la part
d'olivier toussaint parlera donc faux f3
tout simplement pour défendre ce pion h
préparez libérer donc la case g2 pour le
roi oui et après on pourra placer la
tour sur la colonne h et continue l
attaque du roi noir en j'évite donc là
on voit véritablement chez les blancs ce
qu'on peut appeler un plan d' attaque on
voit un plan d'attaqué une position donc
si on prend un petit peu donc les
principes donc de certains pédagogues
une position du roi blanc en g2 qui sera
quand même quelque part plus sûr que la
position du roi noir adverse
oui on regarde un petit peu et ce qui
leur permet finalement donc d'ouvrir la
position et et de continuer l'initiative
on voit que le tout problème des noirs
c'est évidemment que ce cavalier dessin
qui est indispensable donc il peut pas
servir à l'attack puisqu'ils contrôlent
la casaque 6 donc si on veut tenter
quelque chose avec ce cavalier c'est pas
possible il a toujours qualifié 6 qui
sera trop fort le fou des quatre îles a
pas de cave la tour f 5 avait bien placé
il faut absolument ramener la tour
habite mérite pour ça on voit pas trop
plan fou 17
c'est malheureusement quasi impossible à
cause aucun des six qui est tombée cette
pour un peu alternatif mais qui
affaiblirait la structure de tueur de
l'autre côté également ouais donc sa
tête ben n'a absolument pas voulu
permettre ça d'ailleurs je voulais dire
que le joueur mexicain n'avait peut-être
pas eu tort quand il avait décidé de
garder son four g7
oui les tokyoïtes puisque les deux coups
sont c'est le carrefour de théorique de
la position et avec un fond g7 peut-être
que le droit est plus en sécurité c'est
une
une éventualité peut-être brandissent y
joue un coup capitule at war touré fuite
c'est un retour de la tour c'est pas
très joli
c'est pas très joli mais il ne sait plus
quoi faire il ne n'arrive pas à trouver
lui de plans de défense le dessein de
ville un plan d'attaqué actuelle
typiquement un coup qui a l'air d'un
coup d'ordinateurs oui puisque ça
s'intègre pas dans ça s'inscrit pas
vraiment dans un plan mais on aurait
plutôt envie de jouer ou pire
effectivement fourbe et 7 sur 17
elle même donné le ton en baisse à
devoir jouer peut-être à 5 comme si on
jouait d'activer la tour pas raciste b6
peut-être oui même si c'est pas ça pas
l'air top non c'est non donc le jouer à
5 baies 5 étoiles est un plan qui côtoie
régulièrement moyen aussi pour moi ici
touré fuite c'est pas un plan c d'une
sauf un plan alors que les blancs eux
ils ont un plan et de tours h1 d'abord
ou alors il ya peut-être des finesses de
toute façon le prochain vous savez 3g de
avec colonna la fameuse colonne h roger
7 toujours pas planché les noirs
toujours pas de plan à noter que c'est
difficile d'en proposer un mais en tout
cas il était sans doute préférable de
chercher vraiment un truc pour activer
cette tour habite on pense vraiment à
foug 17.8 gnassingbé saint-calais rebond
à saint des saints qui avait 35 c'est
vrai que ça aurait été beaucoup plus
utile de mettre laurent gresset n'a pas
l'air terrible et ça leur salaire solide
pour les noirs finalement quel g5 donc
là petit changement dans le plan enfin
disons amélioration du plan c un homme
brave comme on dit on veut mettre le feu
aux quatre l'adamant g4 et droit en g2
est ce qu'on n'a pas peur sur ce genre
de coup à une
contre attaque qui serait h 6,8 g sync
alors ashes dans cette pétition stéphane
on va le regarder tout de suite
ouais un intéressant 6 donc là en toute
logique on joue qu'à vidéo 4 n'est pas
vraiment de sa crise de pièces qui se
profile donc avis aux cartes et live
actuellement g5 et g5 donc surgissant
que je pense qu'on peut avec l'idée que
commence à attaquer 4 donc qui devient
faible et si on prend oui bon j'essaie
de manger 5 déserté le pion le 5 qui
sautent fou prendre 5
on prend en justice maintenant ouais
héros à suite voilà ça sans visage ça
sans visage c'est compliqué mais le roi
noir et quand même pas vraiment sécurité
encore un nom le roi est alors en aurait
pas de sécurité
mais les noirs ont pas résolu leurs
problèmes de développement met donc ça à
boucher la colonne h la colonne h et
boucher et qui prend ses 5 stéphane quel
point c'est simple on songe et cinq aux
signes vous les 5 et pas mal classé des
violences des points très vite c'est
jouable
oui de toute façon la position après kg
5 et est catastrophique on doute quand
même que je dis ce geste d'impuissance
une solution au problème des non ça a
pas l'air évident du tout mais blanc une
très bonne position d'attaqué c'est
qu'il faut voir et l'ordinateur donc si
ted branch joue mieux avec un ordinateur
est bien ne propose jamais de coupe
constructif en défense c'est là
qu'olivier touzanne a plutôt bien
calculé son kung fu 17 seller maintenant
il ya plus de vic et des six qui est
tombée cet enjeu fou 17 c'est normal fou
aux quatre attaques continuent c'est
grosse attaque quand même là ça peut
menacer des cavaliers pros h7 peut-être
aurait pas encore simplement rage et 2
je crois que moi j'ai donné ensuite on
prend g6 et où rached et a pas besoin de
se presser tourache huit dames g4 ça
monte ça monte grave là la menace
directe qui ébranle cette menace
extrêmement fort puisque après avec la
dame au cat et le fou la dame gk tel
choc at elle changé si ce qui tombe avec
un réseau de maths
donc tout ça ça se passe sur quatre
blanche donc jean luc les noirs doivent
défendre les quatre manches il est noir
doivent absolument défendre le pion g6
et en même temps le pion le 6 qui en
prise par le cavalier la dame donc le
coût qui défend les deux pions c'est le
ku'damm huit dames 8 puisque
effectivement comme tu l'as dit aussi
c'est également aux prises donc des mots
vides c'est normal et là un petit coup
assez brillant
didier touzanne il ne joue pas en manger
de tout de suite il aurait pu le faire
il ne joue pas il joue food et 2,1 coûts
de développement donc ça c'est vraiment
pour prouver aux noirs qui n'ont pas de
défense ils n'ont pas de coût ils
peuvent plus rien faire comme ils sont
complètement muselé c'est un très joli
coup sûr fou prend b2 j'ai envie qu'ils
aient encore tourbe et un taux bien su
surprendre mais c est hélas hélas assez
mortes et abala ça rajoute encore une
tour à l'attaqué
c'est tout ça c'est mental donc l'option
b douai pas vraiment aux prises à quoi
ça sert fou des deux est bien à ramener
la tour quand elle voudra c'est à dire
c'est une c on augmente notre potentiel
data dames 7 les noirs savent plus quoi
faire ils savent que wilson david suite
damas est alors là il faut calculer la
vente qui est proche est oui si aucun de
leurs intéressante donc son roi prend
sur leur projet si ce math nat d'un
projet 6 et surtout reprendre renforcé
d'un projet 6 un projet si c'est la
torah suite j'ai toujours acheté
défendre la tourache est défendue par la
démo 7c lapointe et si c'est pas si
facile de continuer la tacc il ya sans
doute des solutions sont toutes là notre
tour va revenir en défense en g8
oui exactement en fait on ouvre les
lignes contre nous contre nous donc
c'est pas bon damas est un coût qui
tient olivier tauzin toujours rage et de
tranquille tranquille
donc là il peut passer à mende par
exemple doubler les tours que je
tourache 3 wii suivi de tours a h1n1
plan-là karpov méritoire pour ensuite
tour à agen
c'est vrai que ça s'est assez fort il ya
peut-être des combinaisons direct aux
sites et vont mal je pense qu'ils
menacent aussi tout simplement donc
cavaliers pros h7 qui est projetée pour
prendre aux proches c th projet si tu en
prends g6 qui attaquent la tour et après
les charges des tours il pourra rentrer
sur la casa chez sa mère peut revenir en
fuite ou six mois et ça m'a pas l'air de
marcher directement genre si si ça
marche directement puisque appareil
photo par exemple le coup à cinq
cavaliers projets s'ils perdent un temps
donc pour voir la menace des blancs ça
c'est une simulation totale des princes
est non tavel points juste après 7 tours
prend pions proche des six si on prend
g6 tour prochain tour prochain
au prochain tour la suite tourache cet
échec tous rachetés t shirts et la
pointe voilà d'accord donc ça c'est la
menace d'ailleurs ses parents il ya
comprend échecs et ses filles
c'est la menace et damashek et des
machinistes et ça monte donc c'est ce
qui s'est passé en fait menaçant par a
peut-être attention menace imparable
donc les noirs ont décidé finalement de
protéger le roi le plus possible pour
éviter donc
cette combinaison torah j'évite en
jouant tour à g8 il prépare la fuite du
roi par les fuites de 8
oui donc le roi noir qui qui veut donc
finalement quitté les leroy et
finalement c'est la preuve que la
stratégie des blancs donc d'installer de
fragiliser la structure de pion à l'est
le roi est était la bonne
balala on voit dans cette position que
c'est très probablement un énorme succès
puisqu'on a du mal à croire
quoi qu'en dise l'ordinateur qu'il n'y
ait pas de combinaison de gains dans
cette position est d'ailleurs il y en a
une et ce qui est intéressant dans cette
partie c'est que les coûts qui ont été
jouées par les blancs peuvent très bien
très facilement être trouvée par part
par un joueur
oui et quand même arrive à à comment
dire à détruire donc la carapace donc de
l'ordinateur ce qui veut dire que si on
devait comment dire si on devait tirer
une conclusion en tant que programmeur
d'un logiciel il faudrait éliminer donc
cette défense est à vienne le répertoire
offrait sa défense contre g37 défense
entre g3 est passé à autre chose tout
simplement attention de ses peut-être
l'humain qui a choisi aussi l'ouverture
ça c'est ça arrive fréquemment on peut
imposer dans l ordinateur une ouverture
donc la voie la torah j'ai vite vous
avez le temps de réfléchir à la position
pendant que nous discutions
philosophiquement de la puissance
relative des ordinateurs est donc
maintenant il y a le gain immédiat donc
que jean luc a mentionné tout à l'heure
la combinaison qui tue cavaliers prend
h7t est donc un coup de massue la menace
s'est arrangé si ce nom d'un peuple et
isna qui est assez fort donc ici force
et orpond h 7 pions projet six tours
prochain pour tous reproches menaces
d'orage 7 qui gagne la dame
l'instauration avec gain de dames
puisque la dame sera en finale
3 8 tours h7 quand même ça monte attaque
la dame monsigna d'un bouge ça va aller
très vite avec g7 tout simplement par
exemple un coup comme d'amd vite way qui
n'est pas une défense puisque là il ya
chez cet échec
j'ai cet échec est donc suroît plus d'un
matelas mali un match il ya un mode très
simple puisque sur 300 g dames j'ai 5
ans et d'anne jésuite rouge et 6 mars
celui des fusées cisma de classe ça va
très très vite tout simplement tour h7
on ne peut pas bouger la dame il faut
jouer pour g77
c'est joli cette position maintenant
plusieurs solutions
donc on voit que ce retour à schmitt il
ya tour j'ai vite ouais ça tiens ça a
l'air de tenir puisque sûr j'ai cet
échec les dames champions notre projet
c'est donc ça ça ne marche pas damage 5
le coup de levier touzanne tranquille
tranquille avec une menace avec l'idée
que si les noirs font tous reproches
sept ont fait tu en prends h tête et
d'armes aux prochaines courses dames au
prochain coup donc les noirs peuvent
rien faire et la menace c'est de jouer
d'un match 6 et mat qui cloue et ensuite
tour à ce rythme at oui exactement là
tranquille en fait c'est des gens ne
coupe pas facile à voir pour un
ordinateur
oui c'est un message positif
c'est pas évident peut-être la seule
défense c'est peut-être de jouer fouet 8
faut vite c'est un coût possible
je pense pas que ça défendent évidemment
puisque ça a l'air cette pression a
l'air catastrophique donc toujours joué
de damas damages 6 mois louis latour
menace matt des matches 6 c'est vrai que
ça a l'air fort menace mat
la seule défense sekaggya 6 1 comme dans
la partie avec deux faits similaires
on prendrait le cavalier le conali dame
prend ouais donc ici déjà les blancs ont
récupéré leurs pièces
2 il ya égalité matérielle donc ça c'est
normal
et ils ont toujours la tacc ils sont
toujours là tac beaucoup de possibilités
de conclure notamment le coup et 5 c'est
exactement similaire à la partie donc on
va se contenter de regarder la partie
qui après damage 5 donc il n'y a pas eu
faut vite qu'ils étaient un coût
possible
il est le foot pro b de autant mourir le
ventre plein exactement puisque
maintenant en plus aux menaces de procès
lancé aujourd'hui au moins inscrit à
inscrire au cas où les blancs seront
peuplés nord vont gagner la partie
damages 6 ça y est là c'est mathématique
masse matin un gain mathématiques menace
matt menace matour h huit cavaliers
seuls défense donc cavalier m6 seule
défense parce que surtout rage suite
lecavalier 6 reviendrait sur laquelle j
8 exactement c'est une interception de
ce matt du couloir
ce qui fait qu'on est obligé donc de
prendre ce cavalier
toujours couronnées cet ouvrage suit
exactement dames 3 et m6 qui libère donc
qui libère la case de 7 pour le roi qui
offre une case au roi savoir bien pour
les noirs fin ça a l'air d'aller pour la
noire ça a l'air d'aller pour les noirs
mais là donc les blancs ont toujours
l'initiative et vont exploiter donc vont
exploiter le jeu sur cases noires en
jouant tour à schwyz 3e set et f5 f/4
5-5 très forts menacent tout juste mais
la nage le lac de bienne les dames
whaychi canada mais une fois de plus à
celui menace de crues la dame menace de
la dame et de la prendre
donc là il n'y a pas 36 défense c'est
très simple on voit tout de suite que
dame 5 perd rapidement comme un fou j'ai
cinq échecs mais aura des six forcé et x
4 enfermement faux
de nouveau on peut aussi regarder donc
au lieu de dâm sen qu'on peut regarder
le ku'damm d'agathe à l'égard d'amd qui
perdrait assez simplement à après il ya
dieu fils échec qui arrivent ici le
meilleur quoi la bête d'un match 4 en
fait qui gagne aussi très vite wen à
mach 4 mètres est vrai qu un math
probable d'un match et c'est assez fort
ouais donc sur deux même si c'est très
sain qu'il y à fouché 5
oui et ce roi des six sur l'autre cuias
faut être quatre ou indécise faut être
quatre ou cinq
et là on peut jouer la même si celui
d'amd huit dents mais aussi celui de
vous prendre un simple oui ou non un
nombre d'indécis sud inde et vite c'est
bien là le 6 d'un f3 c'est cette force
et d'amd vite dam des huit ans des six
aux dames b8 à huy maintenant on passe
par baby tu vois la très jolie me sert
aux seuls les dames les rythmes
d'amérique
c'est superbe c'est une très belle
variante ouais on va la revoir bon ça
c'est des variantes que l'ordinateur
calcule très vite alors maintenant
jean-luc la sas et c'est là que c'est
important d'avoir un ordinateur
l'ordinateur en quelques instants il va
dire matt oui oui on va dire que
l'humain a fait son travail il la
trouvait donc les manoeuvres
stratégiques les plus importantes
le choix de l'ouverture et l'ordinateur
fait le reste quand on arrive dans la
position qui est gagnante pourquoi
perdre son temps à calculer les
variantes ce qui compte finalement dans
ce type de rencontre c'est d'avoir les
bonnes idées mais d'utiliser la machine
pour le calcul pour le reste exactement
d'un mach 4 donc la voir en 3d 6 x 4
échecs e5 forcé et maintenant la petite
quadrille angulation la cadrature du cnd
6-3 10-8 forcé damas huit ils sont un
des six daims belgique ou un v8
intimâtes en fuite permis c'est joli
donc après pts 5
il n'y a plus de défenses donc peut-être
brand jour wade 6 x 4 échecs tchèque
donc là il n'est pas question de jouer
soit 5 puisque sauf aux 5 fu g saint
gall c'est la partie mais sur cinq il y
avoue j'ai 5 au 6 mai lan et d'un mépris
jour où s est il ya foule g5 bon quoi
qu'il arrive du raf ou g5 en fait 5 fuji
ou g5 et là c'est terminé
tout simplement et oui je veux jamais
perdu oui donc l'aller les noirs ont
feuilleté ils vont fêter un petit peu
mais sans trouver quelqu'un défense ou
et tour plonger 6 faut point m6
une dame de plus tout reprend h 6 tours
prend donc ici on a une tour de plus une
tour de plus
bon attention à ces trois pions c'est
vrai qu'ils étaient déjà arrivés
jusqu'ici ça serait dangereux mais là
ils sont vraiment trop loin
donc pas de problème fous l'camp fous
qu'il faut deux ans plus échangé des
fous tout reprend et là le problème
c'est que ce roi aux cinq qui a l'air de
gagner le fou et bien non il adorait
cette contre attaque sur l'autre donc
après avoir fait la partie a continué
c'est vrai que c'est une constante chez
ces parties du chantier du monde elle
continue toujours jusqu'au bout alors
pour eux un niveau de jeu énorme et les
joueurs n'abandonne pas donc oui nous on
y croit un message à m enfin ça faisait
dix ans que si on peut se tromper aussi
comme c'est pas un échiquier réel on
peut se tromper sur la souris ça arrive
oui comme le slip voilà la souris qui
glisse voilà c'est ça et on se trompe et
on lâche la pièce au mauvais endroit et
on perd la partie
c'est peut-être aussi ainsi que la
plupart des joueurs ne sont pas des
professionnels puisque en général dans
ce type de position un professionnel un
professionnel a confiance donc dans le
jeu ton adversaire et abandonne et là
les joueurs donc qu'ils sont plus plus
là finalement pour le fun et pour pour
l'amusement tentent leur chance jusqu'au
bout
tu en prends aussi ça je ne sais pas
s'il est là pour le fun 3.26 qui on
prend ça c'est les 5 donc la maintenance
et un gain technique c'est à dire que le
roi blanc va stopper les points noirs et
les deux pions blancs vont tout
simplement avancé à l'est le roi noir ne
peut pas à la fois empêché le pion des
et le pion g dames voilà là on empêche
l'option d'avancé mais normal maintenant
y'a plus qu'à pousser oui on peut jouer
en votre 3 enfin tout gagne on regarde
juste la conclusion d'olivier touzanne 1
et 4 4 et 5 g 5
complètement impuissants les noirs dans
cet étang voilà ça c'est une tentative
de l'ordinateur mais l'ordinateur pour
s'être hors des villes
j'ai six mois c'est 7 et la bid a mangé
avance adam
donc voilà on va conclure quand même sur
sur ce débat alors jean-luc on assistait
à une compétition d chaque avancée
c'est à dire sommes plus ordinateur
c'est pratiquement certain
compte tenu du niveau de jeu des partis
du fait que les joueurs trouvent quand
même systématiquement les coûts cas pas
de gaffe des coûts complexe ya jamais de
gaffes
donc qu'est ce qu'il va faire la
différence entre donc entre tous ces
pseudos qui ne sont même pas forcément
des joueurs je crois que ça fait partie
donc des grands débats qui sont lancés
par cette compétition
c'est à dire que il me semble
actuellement que
qu' il n'est pas facile de dire si un
ordinateur seul peut peut vaincre
n'importe n'importe quelle équipe
ouais c'est à dire quand je dis
n'importe quelle équipe c'est-à-dire
homeplus machine oui en plus machine
donc l'ordinateur le plus puissant
est-ce que tout seul peut battre donc un
homme plus une machine femme très
performante
ou est-ce qu'il faut l'intervention
humaine ça c'est la question que je me
pose actuellement et c'est pas vraiment
une vraie question c'est plutôt si un
ordinateur capable de battre n'importe
qui à quoi ça sert d'organiser des
compétitions sur internet oui ça peut
également une surtout si l'ordinateur
est commercialement commercialisés c'est
à celui qui manie mule qui manie mieux
le mieux l'ordinateur c'est vrai mais le
problème c'est que tant qu'on n'aura pas
répondu à ma question
on ne pourra pas répondre à une autre
question c'est que tant que l humain
aura oral à le conduire aura la
possibilité de battre avec une machine
de battre une machine seul
oui on pourra regarder ce genre de
compétition la compétition aura un sens
oui avait d'un côté c'est pas forcément
le meilleur joueur qui sera capable de
faire peut-être le meilleur sens bien le
meilleur joueur évidemment ça le jour le
mieux préparé à ce type de rencontre est
tout à fait mais le fait est que c'est
quand même des qualifications pour un
tournoi où là il y aura plus
d'ordinateurs après c'est à dire qu'ils
vont devoir jouer dans ses face à face
ou non c'est pas puisqu'il ya quelques
années il ya eu 1
en allemagne je crois un joueur qui
avait joué un open oui il y avait une
oreillette et il savait pas du tout joué
aux échecs
on s'est douté qu'ils avaient un
ordinateur parce que il faisait de très
belles parties il arrive avec de battre
des grands maîtres etc puis des fois ils
réfléchissaient une heure sur un coût
qui était évident il ne jouait pas parce
qu'en fait tu savais même pas jose
d'échec et il joue et que les coups
qu'on lui donne l ordinateur par le café
mais en fait il avait été repéré le jour
où il a abattu un très fort grand maître
et l'autre fois grand maître abandonne
et lui dit évidemment il ya va très vite
bon alors que évidemment la position
très compliqué personne sur terre ne
pouvait annoncer maintenant 8 déc ça
m'embête
donc là on est libre écoute du foot nous
c'est pas possible moi je vais car
ordinateur de toute façon c'est pas très
grave il ya huit places qualificatives
par cette compétition et je suis sûr que
les joueurs qui est qu'ils n'ont pas le
niveau se font éliminer probablement au
premier tour mais on peut tout à fait
envisager peut-être que ce genre de
qualification puisse servir un
championnat du monde mais chaque avancée
justement ouais enfin pas tim dyer
oui ça devrait être ça pourra pas de ça
pour être bien accueilli un spectacle
mais les ados joueurs tout à fait mais
on peut très bien jouer aux échecs ans
on est considéré comme un ordinateur
mais j'avais organisé d'ailleurs le
match entre kasparov et les grandes
écoles les bandes et celles qui joueront
pour ceux qui jouent et en consultation
en équipe donc c'est de son ordinateur
sans ordinateur mais effectivement le
nom mais là ça aurait été dur comme pour
que c'est à dire fourquet scorff
effectivement même à l'époque l'une
ordinateur était quand même assez fort
mais
c'est intéressant le jeu paraît qu'il
pourrait pourquoi pas le vrai c'est du
vrai jeu par équipe deux fois c'est
effectivement on ya plusieurs réfléchira
même pas la même partie actualité
toujours avec le match etienne bacrot
contre émile suite office qui donc match
au sommet match annuel en maintenant
c'est devenu une tradition stéphane
depuis que nous avions été voir maintenu
mais aussi une macro 1.169 skie toujours
mon avait été donc filmé le match avec
bay lightning - tout à fait il avait
déjà joué contre corneau il avait déjà
joué contre les vannes aronian qui est
maintenant un des meilleurs joueurs du
monde short contre shore de la garde
populaire
il a toute une liste d'adversaires à
cette adresse et là ils s'attaquent aux
champions d'europe
oui alors à noter quand même que
faites-vous chez lui et surtout ses
matchs il a eu beaucoup de mal il ya en
fait il a perdu contre courant il a
perdu green trop short
donc il y avait c'était des joueurs
quand même un cran au-dessus à l'époque
maintenant ils jouent bien me sauve ski
qui chante en europe qui est donc très
très fort et par contre cette fois on
sent qu'il a la possibilité de gagner
ils ont même fait mieux
ils ont du mal à 150 chacun sait ça donc
ils ont des très forts classement elo
donc le match est normalement très
équilibré jean luc est ce que tu as
suivi un peu ton camarade de club ne l'a
pas vraiment d'accord avec l'analyse de
stéphane c'est que les milices tous ici
les champions d'europe c'est que il est
probablement actuellement plus en forme
que des corps cheney ou autres joueurs
ah oui je dis que cette cette année j'ai
pour la première fois il a le niveau
pour battre un joueur de cette classe de
cette classe là ben non je pense que oui
il a le niveau mais son adversaire est
plus fort que ses adversaires habituels
puisque c'est un jour dix ans qui est n
1 progressaient et c'est ce que je veux
dire c'est qu'elle est ce qu etienne a
considérablement progressé et que et que
et que mémé que son adversaire est plus
fort que d'habitude
il est lé plus rien plus fort que son
coaching ou believe si oui enfin
certainement pas plus fort que short ou
qui quand même et d'un calibre vraiment
impressionnant actuellement les
résultats de choc ne sont pas excellents
je pense que je sors que j'inclus n'est
pas en très grande forme puisqu'il avait
perdu contre igor au chocolat du monde
par exemple moi ils m'embrassent peu
importe
en tout cas suite au ski c'est un
adversaire assez remarquable et le score
après trois rondes avantage etienne qui
mène 2 1
il a gagné une partie et fait deux nuls
donc vous pouvez consulter les partis
sur le site www.eurostar.com il ya
toutes les parties à télécharger et vous
verrez une deuxième partie totalement
stupéfiante vraiment incroyable alors je
ne sais pas si vous l'avez vu en tout
cas elle est délirante oui mais elle
s'arrête alors que les kelly avant
qu'elle commence
elle commence sa position extrêmement
compliqué s'arrête abruptement donc être
un peu contre le spectacle marché sur la
deuxième partie alors que quand ça c'est
la position ça s'arrête
il ya une grande dynamique dans le jeu
quand on peut pas dire le contraire
les noirs ont monté une grande demande
travail extrêmement compliqué donc
deuxième partie de ce match à
télécharger sur le site d'europe échec
par exemple dernière dernière chose
maintenant on va peut-être aborder les
tournois à venir donc là nous avons
notre spécialiste en tournoi puisqu'il
s'agit d'un joueur très actif jean-luc
chavanon qui a étudié pour vous tous les
tournois à venir donc pour ce mois
d'octobre novembre ces deux mois pouvait
donc beaucoup de tournois la toussaint
dont une actualité très chargée beaucoup
de tournois dans toute la france donc
évidemment je pense qu'on peut pas ne
pas parler en premier jean-luc du
tournoi de bastia ont quand même
phénoménal c'est votre papa c'est donc à
côté du tournoi de bastia donc un
tournoi qui a six cent mille francs de
prix je crois 600 litres en dotation
totale et ou avec une affiche
exceptionnelle puisque je crois qu'il y
aura donc mai
non de lundi à wisches madone à nantes
qui a gagné l'an dernier mais qui va
jouer et enrichir of plus de nombreux
grands aigre plus morose émirati
simplement les deux finalistes des
championnats du monde de l'an dernier
millions à tomber sauf kasparov trafic a
priori way qui eux on a du mal à les
attraper
en tout cas ce tournoi dacia va être
tout à fait exceptionnel ça se passe sur
trois jours ou quatre s'espacent oui
donc sur sur trois jours donc pour les
grands maîtres et la compétition donc
avec les tournois annexes dure quatre
jours donc
l'intrus a déjà été joué là bas tu peux
peut-être nous décrire un peu le cadre
oui donc j'en avais déjà été filmée
bastia donc est un tournoi qui
qui est très bien organisé donc dans une
très belle salle et c'est une ville
très très sympa c'est très sympa de
façon d'aller jouer en corse
donc avis corse merci de nous accueillir
en tout cas on essaiera d'aller nombreux
vous voir on se rappelle stéphane du
match etienne bacrot jeudi paul bien
évidemment mais messieurs etienne bacrot
donc toujours dans ces histoires de
match c'était le premier direct réalisé
je n'ai guère premier direct de
diagonale sinistre et même premier
direct de marché chez que lui sur
internet de l'histoire des échecs
enfin en vidéo et en vidéo sur
l'atteinte idéaux tout à fait voilà donc
il ya ce tournoi là et maintenant il y
en a aussi d'autres en france alors ça
si vous avez envie de jouer un tournoi
la toussaint voilà des notes en main qui
dure à peu près une semaine je crois
qu'on va faire un petit tour de france
donc si vous êtes dans le nord de la
france vous pouvez aller jouer au
touquet par exemple lors le touquet
extrêmement sympathique tournoi vraiment
très bien organisés dans une énorme
salle tout en pierres massives et ses
frais une station balnéaire qui a
beaucoup de charme et donc un très
sympathique et vous pourrez essayer au
passage la soupe de poissons du
restaurant chez terra il faut pas faire
de pub enfin en tout cas elle est
vraiment délicieuse donc l esi n'ayez
pas peur
elle devrait au capreau si enfin allez y
le touquet c'est vraiment très bien ce
qui nous attend demain il y aura un
tournoi donc si vous habitez en touraine
ya un tour à tour ils tombent très très
fort donc le twin towers un travail très
dur 3 4 jo est exactement
je crois qu'il vient ton à sautron aussi
dans la région nantaise alors il paraît
qu'il est extrêmement relevé ce tournoi
puisque à ce jour devrait déjà plus de
30 titres inscrits donc si vous êtes fan
de ce genre titre et si vous avez envie
d'en rencontrer bien aller à sautron
c'est là où il y aura probablement le
plus beau palmarès après basta
évidemment et si vous aimez le soleil
vajou conseil soit l'open de toulon dont
m leur fille qui va être très très fort
qui se joue au palais neptune donc bon
le champ de la côte d'azur est également
le tournoi de menton donc le tour ne
mentons que auxquelles je vais
participer
donc là on aura l'occasion de voir le
jour le plus bronzé du circuit et voilà
donc il y aura aussi mon ami
tony kosten qui va jouer le grand maître
international et d'autres grands matches
ce sera aussi un tournoi très
sympathique dans une ville dans une
ville qui a beaucoup de charme
donc alors pour résumer on va conseiller
donc par région allez dans votre région
ça c'est le premier choix deuxième chose
si vous voulez voir des très très fortes
remettre des très bons joueurs allaient
à bastia et ensuite si vous voulez vous
amuser manger de la bonne soupe de
poisson vous allez au touquet pour avoir
toutes les informations sur les tournois
vous allez sur le site fédéral
www.fff.fr et là vous aurez les
informations sur tous les tournois avec
les téléphones des organisateurs les
dates les cadences bref tout pour passer
de très bonnes vacances de la toussaint
dans le milieu des échecs donc on va
arrêter là cette édition stéphane rendez
vous la semaine prochaine si dieu le
veut maintenant c'est comme ça qu'on dit
voilà
jean-luc merci d'avoir participé à cette
édition merci j'espère que
quelle aventure va continuer sinon bah
jeudi bientôt tous les téléspectateurs
et est à toi et moi et elle stéphane
donc nous souhaitons bonne chance en
tout cas tous nos français engagé sur ce
championnat du monde qualificative par
internet et on vous dit rendez vous la
semaine prochaine pour une nouvelle et
peut être dernière émission de diagonale
merci de nous avoir suivis